when should a writer quit their
full-time job only when writing has
become one that can replace that
full-time job basically I would say
which you know is you kind of know it
when that happens I think I mean
obviously if you have a full-time job
because you need that amount of income
and you can't get it if you quit because
writing isn't isn't bringing it then I
probably wouldn't be quitting I mean I
think most people tend to get I don't
see people quitting their jobs even when
they have a nibble a professional nibble
at writing because you can have a nibble
that doesn't turn in anything even you
get an agent even you get a job even if
you get a job on writing staff of a hit
show that could be over in six months
and you may not get another one so I
mean you're gonna suspend your full-time
day job while you're on that hit show
because you probably have to go to work
every day on the show at the offices you
know with the rest of the writers but I
would say it's great if you have other
ways to earn a living that you like and
that have growth potential and no reason
to let those go but there may come a
time where you have to stop because I'm
writing on a movie and they need me you
know full-time for the next six months
they're paying me half a million dollars
or whatever that'd be a good problem
that what about the notion that people
think that I just need six months gonna
take this time off and I'm gonna this is
gonna go great I'm gonna get up every
day and I have this regimen and this
practice I'm gonna crank these pages out
do you think that really works or you
think that it's just this wrong romantic
version of writing I I don't know if it
works I've never really done that it may
be work sometimes for some people I'm
more believer that you carve out time in
your regular life every day or like five
days a week so if that means getting up
early for an hour
I mean Ron Bass used to be a lawyer and
he would wake up I the story was at 3
a.m. and right for four hours and then
go be an entertainment lawyer all day
back before he was a famous screenwriter
but even you know an hour at night an
hour at whatever half-hour you know
every Saturday and Sunday for two hours
each and then although I even that I
think is not as good as five days a week
but the idea of I'm gonna go take this
time off and then when that time is over
I don't have time to write anymore I
don't
thing tends to work as well that's what
this say you can't take a retreat for a
week or a month or I think John August
does that he goes to a hotel in Las
Vegas to pump out a first draft in three
weeks or whatever like a change of
scenery or getting away from the normal
daily responsibilities can work but I
think it works best combined with you
also have a daily writing practice and
you're moving it forward
every day in some way as well do you
think the notion of wanting to take this
long stretch of time out actually is
damaging because you lose touch with the
day-to-day because when you're not
working or you're like on vacation your
mind is not really in the reality of the
day-to-day your troubles are different
your your your you know what I'm saying
cuz you're you're not stressing being on
someone else's time schedule which you
really are when you have a job you're at
the mercy of their scheduling pretty
much so do you think you lose touch with
with writing what you're saying when you
go off and write and leave your regular
life while you're writing not be as good
because you're out of touch with regular
life I don't really see that as an issue
I think it's okay to not be currently
immersed in your normal life to be able
to write I think it's just more a danger
that somebody just never writes until
they have that magical stretch of time
where they think they're gonna write all
day every day and it's going to be great
I think most writers who are
professionals tend to more have a block
of time they do it kind of every day
there may be a shorter block but they're
always kind of doing it and moving it
forward
you